well it was just three weeks ago that
ariana grande was set to walk down the
aisle with Pete Davidson but they ended
their relationship and then that
followed the death of her ex Mac Miller
two very heartbreaking events - still
for Ariana the show must go on
[Music]
the 25 year old seemed upbeat on NBC's a
very wicked Halloween taking the stage
for the first time since her recent
traumas are a mystery well last night a
Bette Midler's hula ween party for the
New York restoration project a costume
frankie grande assured us his sister is
okay says August Ariana's canceled two
other performances and also nearly
backed out of this one revealing on
Instagram quote almost let my anxiety
ruin this for me
she's working really hard and getting
prepped for tour and another album like
it's too much
[Music]
Ariana's covered up her Pete tattoo he
did the same before the split boa source
says the rekindling is possible quote
right now they just needed to step away
and regain some clarity on their wants
and needs grande is leaning on family we
just had a game night together the other
night was me Mommy and Nona Wow I could
have bro their ex alright well Ariane I
did say that she was emotionally ready
to return to Tori
her sweetener world tour kicks off March
the 18th and Albany New York
[Music]